Hyundai unveiled its first electric sedan on Thursday...
...as it pushes to challenge Tesla's dominance of the electric vehicle market.
The Ioniq 6 will cost around 42,000 dollars...
...and can travel up to 380 miles on a single charge.
It will be a direct competitor to Tesla's best-selling vehicle,...
...the Model 3 sedan.
The Ioniq 6 is one of more than 30 electric vehicles that Hyundai,...
...along with its sister company Kia and Genesis,...
...plan to introduce over the next eight years.
The South Korean automaker hopes to secure a 12% share...
...in the global EV market by 2030.
Hyundai's new electric sedan will be available in South Korea this year,...
...and the US market launch is expected in the first quarter of next year.
It comes after Hyundai announced its plans to build dedicated EV plants...
...both at home and in the United States.